a victim of emotional abuse and happy
that it's over Selena Gomez is getting
real about her complicated relationship
with ex Justin Bieber in a new interview
with NPR we're learning more about the
meaning behind her single lose you to
love me you promised the world enough
fell for it
I felt I didn't get a respectful closure
it's not a hateful song it's it's a song
that is saying I had something beautiful
and I would never deny that it wasn't
that it was very difficult and I'm happy
he gets over saying goodbye to Justin
Bieber who I miss remember something
about yeah to get the name and
the 27 year old said the song helped her
cope with the pain I found the strength
in it it's dangerous to stay and a
victim mentality and I'm not being
disrespectful I do feel I was a victim
to certain abuse when asked if she met
emotional abuse Celina responded yes but
the rare singer is rising up had to
understand the choices I was making as
much as I definitely don't want to spend
the rest of my life talking about this I
am really proud that I can say I feel
the strongest I've ever felt and I've
found a way to just walk through it with
as much grace as possible I think that
the whole objective of the album is
self-love and acceptance et has reached
out to Justin Bieber's rep for comment
[Music]
you